on
[Musique]
doit à la fois gérer aujourd'hui mais on
doit aussi prévoir demain et donc
investir dans l'innovation pouvoir
propulsé style et design dans une offre
très active qui va intéresser les
marchés c'est à la fois pouvoir
personnaliser l'intérieur avions et
offrir de nouvelles nouveaux outils de
nouvelles
opportunités pour les pour les
compagnies aériennes d'aller chercher de
ce qu'on appelle la brand experience
[Musique]
ce financement du plan de relance on en
est très heureux c'est formidable pour
nous c'est un financement tendues dans
le cas de la réindustrialisation des
territoires alors si on s'intéresse aux
territoires de l'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est la
première plateforme générique de mesure
et d'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle
son objectif c'est d'être en mesure de
caractériser et l'environnement de
fonctionnement de ces systèmes
intelligents c'est à dire d'être capable
de dire quand est ce qu'il fonctionne et
quand elle ne fonctionne pas
notre rôle c'est de concevoir des
systèmes qui vont purifier cet autre
ville pour la rendre propre à
l'utilisation par les scientifiques que
ce soit dans la recherche contre la
cancérologie par exemple en cancérologie
ou pour ce soit des analyses chimiques
dans l'environnement l'alimenter
[Musique]
le concept des bd grand marché vrac y va
c'est un débat d de centre-ville mais
qu'on installe en périphérie et sur
lequel on va ajouter tous les produits
frais avec des commerçants engagé locaux
qui m'ont rejoint dans le projet pour
défendre les mêmes valeurs que celles
que je voulais porter avec des valides
[Musique]